y la caravana del fondo lleva forraje
para los animales que regresan.
Comprendí que no era posible tomar una foto de este tipo
desde una nave convencional.
Un avión va demasiado rápido,
un helicóptero genera demasiado ruido
y demasiada corriente de aire por debajo,
y pensé que este pequeño y loco aparato volador
podría abrir las puertas
a un nuevo modo de ver zonas remotas del paisaje africano
como nunca antes había sido posible.
Permítanme mostrarles cómo funciona.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Puede parecer un tanto peligroso, pero no soy un tipo arriesgado.
Soy un fotógrafo que vuela, con el sólo objeto de tomar fotos.
My altitud preferida es de 60 a 150 metros,
que es la distancia para ver el mundo en tres dimensiones,
pero también a escala humana.
Creo que gran parte de lo que hice esos años en África
podría hacerse con un drone,
pero los drones no han sido diseñados para explorar.
Vuelan apenas los 20 minutos que dura su batería
y tienen unos 3 km de autonomía,
y todo lo que se ve
aparece en una pequeña pantalla delante de uno.
Pero a mí me gusta explorar.
Yo quiero ir más allá del horizonte y descubrir cosas nuevas y raras,
como esta caldera volcánica en Níger.
Si miran el altímetro en mi pierna izquierda,
verán que estoy a unos 1600 m del suelo.
Volar a esa altura realmente daba miedo,
pero si hablan con un piloto profesional,
les dirá que la altitud es en realidad una amiga,
porque cuanto más alto te encuentras
más tiempo tienes para resolver problemas.
(Risas)
Como buen principiante que era, pensé que así tendría más tiempo
para gritar durante el descenso.
(Risas)
Para calmarme, empecé a tomar fotos,
y a medida que lo hacía, retomé la sensatez
mientras me zarandeaba el viento Harmattan
que provenía del rincón superior derecho de esta imagen
y vi cómo se había cubierto de arena todo el cráter.
Cuando llegué al norte de Chad, encontré otro tipo de volcán,
con su exterior totalmente erosionado
y lo único que quedaba era el antiguo núcleo.
Allí, en medio del Sahara,
parecía como si a la Tierra le hubiesen arrancado la piel viva.
Por debajo de gran parte del Sahara fluye un enorme acuífero de agua dulce.
En la cuenca, el agua a veces se filtra hacia la superficie.
Si camináramos por esos palmerales,
podríamos beber agua dulce a nuestros pies.
Pero ¿y ese lago de agua verde?
Debido a la extrema evaporación, es más salada que el agua de mar
y casi no alberga vida.
En Níger, me sorprendió ver a los pobladores
explotar otro tipo manantiales en el desierto.
Vemos aquí cómo mezclaron el fango salino con agua de manantial
y lo extendieron en lagunas de aguas poco profundas
que, al evaporarse, dan lugar a este espectáculo de colores.
Desde lo alto, también se observa muy bien la agricultura.
Esta imagen fue tomada al sur de Algeria,
cuyos habitantes han aprendido a cultivar en campos de dunas móviles
aprovechando las aguas subterráneas menos profundas.
Fue también maravilloso ver la adaptación de los animales al paisaje africano.
Esta fotografía fue tomada en el Lago Amboseli,
muy cerca de la frontera, aquí en Kenia.
Los elefantes han abierto una red de senderos
entre los pastizales de las aguas poco profundas del lago,
separados a una distancia que permite sólo a ellos, con su larga trompa,
acceder a las hierbas más suculentas.
En Namibia, las cebras han aprendido a vivir en un ambiente sin lluvias.
Estos pastizales son irrigados por la densa niebla costera
que cubre la zona todas las mañanas.
¿Ven esas formaciones sin vegetación?
Se las llama "círculos de las hadas",
de origen aún desconocido para los científicos.
Este es el monte Visoke, que tiene en su cima un cráter
con un pequeño lago, a una altura de 3700 metros.
Forma el techo del Gran Valle del Rift
y también separa Ruanda del Congo.
Es además el centro de la reserva del legendario gorila de montaña,
sin dudas la atracción más redituable de Ruanda,
y su conservación ha sido sumamente exitosa en este lado de la frontera.
Ruanda tiene la mayor densidad de población rural en África,
y la vi en casi todos los rincones que visité en el país.
He oído decir que la lucha por la tierra
fue uno de los motivos del conflicto
que llevó al genocidio en la década del 90.
Hace unos años, regresé a Sudán del Sur
y me sorprendió lo mucho que habían cambiado las cosas.
Los dinka aún adoraban a su ganado,
pero habían cambiado sus lanzas por Kalashnikovs.
Los campos de ganado se veían desde el aire
aun más espectaculares de lo imaginable,
pero también allí cambiaron las cosas.
¿Ven esos puntitos azules?
Los dinka se habían adaptado a la nueva realidad,
y ahora cubrían sus refugios de papiro
con lona de los convoys de la ONU cargados con alimentos.
En Mali, el pueblo bozo ha aprendido a desarrollarse
al ritmo palpitante del río Níger.
Cuando la temporada de lluvias termina y las aguas se retiran,
cultivan arroz en los terrenos fértiles.
Esa ciudad en el rincón inferior de la derecha es Gao,
punto de partida de las principales rutas comerciales en el Sahara.
Al final de la cosecha,
los bozo recogen la paja de arroz residual
y la mezclan con fango para reforzar sus techos y la mezquita del poblado.
Habré sobrevolado más de una docena de pueblos como este
a lo largo del río Níger,
cada uno con su particularidad, con un patrón distinto.
Cada mezquita era una obra maestra de la escultura,
y no había dos iguales.
Volé por todo el mundo, pero nada se compara
con la diversidad cultural de África.
Esto se aprecia en cada uno de sus países:
desde Marruecos
a Etiopía,
a Sudáfrica,
a Mozambique,
a Sudán del Sur,
hasta Mali.
El despliegue de ambientes
y de adaptaciones culturales a esos ambientes
es absolutamente extraordinario,
y la historia es fascinante también.
La vista aérea es una ventana única para entrar
en las primeras etapas de la historia colonial.
Esto es Cirene, en la costa montañosa de Libia,
fundada por los griegos en 700 a. C. como centro de estudio.
Y Timgad, donde hoy está Algeria,
fue fundada por los romanos en 100 d. C.
para albergar a los soldados ancianos ya retirados.
Me maravilla pensar
que el norte de África fue alguna vez el granero del Imperio Romano.
Pero 700 años después de su construcción, Timgad quedó sepultada en la arena,
y aun entonces, el clima de África era más húmedo que hoy.
El clima del continente sigue cambiando,
y eso se evidencia en todas partes,
como en la garganta del Ziz,
donde un inesperado temporal de lluvias pasó raudamente por el Sahara
y cubrió las montañas de nieve.
Jamás imaginé que llegaría a ver palmeras datileras en la nieve;
pero ese día los niños se divirtieron en grande, jugando con bolas de nieve.
Lo que me intriga es cómo harán los africanos
para adaptarse a este clima que cambia a gran velocidad.
En un continente tan dinámico y diverso como África,
a veces pareciera que lo único constante es el cambio.
Pero si algo aprendí
es que los africanos son grandes improvisadores,
siempre adaptándose y buscando el camino hacia adelante.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)